in civil case number CL 2019-2911
Mr Depp's claim against Ms heard
one as to the statement appearing in the
online op-ed entitled Amber Heard I
spoke up against sexual violence and
faced our culture's wrath that has to
change
in the Washington Post online edition
quote I spoke up against sexual violence
and faced our culture's rat that has to
change end quote
do you find that Mr Depp has proven all
the elements of defamation answer yes
has Mr Depp proven by a greater weight
of the evidence that question the
statement was made or published by Ms
heard answer yes
the state question the statement was
about Mr Depp answer yes
question the statement was false answer
yes
question the statement has a defamatory
implication about Mr Depp answer yes
question the Del the defamatory
implication was designed and intended by
misheard answer yes
question due to circumstances
surrounding the publication of the
statement it conveyed a defamatory
implication
to someone who saw it other than Mr
death
answer yes
do you find that Mr Depp has proven by
clear and convincing evidence that
misheard acted with actual malice answer
yes
two as to the statement appearing in the
op-ed entitled a transformative moment
for women in the Washington Post print
edition and the online op-ed Amber Heard
I spoke up against sexual violence and
faced our culture's wrath that has to
change in the Washington Post online
edition
quote then two years ago I became a
public figure representing domestic
abuse and I felt the full force of our
culture's wrath for women who speak out
end quote
do you find that Mr Depp has proven all
the elements of defamation answer yes
has Mr Depp proven by a greater weight
of the evidence
that question the statement was made or
published by Ms heard answer yes
question the statement was about Mr Depp
answer yes
question the statement was false answer
yes
question the statement has a defamatory
implication about Mr Depp answer yes
question the defamatory implication was
designed and intended by misheard answer
yes
question due to circumstances
surrounding the publication of the
statement
it conveyed a defamatory implication to
someone who saw it other than Mr Depp
answer yes
do you find that Mr Depp has proven by
clear and convincing evidence that
misheard acted with actual malice answer
yes
three as to this statement appearing in
the op-ed entitled a transformative
moment for women in the Washington Post
print edition and the online op-ed
I heard I spoke up against sexual
violence and faced our culture's rat
that has to change in the Washington
Post online edition
quote I had the rare vantage point of
seeing in real time how institutions
protect men accused of abuse end quote
do you find that Mr Depp has proven all
the elements of defamation answer yes
has Mr Depp proven by a greater weight
of the evidence that question the
statement was made or published by Ms
heard answer yes
question the statement was about Mr
death answer yes
question the statement was false
answer yes
question this statement has a defamatory
implication about Mr Depp answer yes
question the defamatory implication was
designed and intended by Ms heard answer
yes
question due to circumstances
surrounding the publication of this
statement it conveyed a defamatory
implication
to someone who saw it other than Mr
death
answer yes
do you find that Mr death has proven by
clear and convincing evidence that
misheard acted with actual malice answer
yes
as against Amber Heard we the jury award
compensatory damages in the amount of 10
million dollars
as against Amber Heard we the jury award
punitive damages in the amount of five
million dollars
in civil case number CL
2019-2911 Ms heard's claim against Mr
Depp
one
as to this statement appearing in the
April 8 2020 online edition of The Daily
Mail quote
Amber Heard and her friends in the media
use fake sexual violence allegations as
both a sword and shield depending on
their needs
they have selected some of her sexual
violence hopes facts as the sword
inflict inflicting them on the public
and Mr Depp
do you find that Miss heard has proven
all the elements of defamation answer no
two as to this statement appearing in
the April 27th 2020 online edition of
The Daily Mail
quote simply this was an ambush a hoax
they set Mr Depp up by calling the cops
but the first attempt did not do the
trick
the officers came to the penthouses
thoroughly searched and interviewed and
left after seeing no damage to face or
property
so Amber and her friends spilled a
little wine and roughed the place up
got their story straight under the
direction of a lawyer and publicist and
then placed a second call to 9-1-1 end
quote
do you find that misheard has proven all
the elements of defamation answer yes
has misheard proven by a greater weight
of the evidence that question Mr Waldman
while acting as an agent for Mr death
made or published the statement answer
yes
question the statement was about Ms
heard answer yes
question the statement was seen by
someone other than misheard answer yes
question the statement was false answer
yes
do you find that Miss heard has proven
by clear and convincing evidence that
the statement by mayor Waldman was made
with actual malice answer yes
three as to this statement appearing in
the April 27 2020 online edition of The
Daily Mail quote we've reached the
beginning of the end of Miss heard's
abuse hoax against Johnny Depp end quote
do you find that misheard has proven all
the elements of defamation answer no
as against John C depth II we the jury
award compensatory damages in the amount
of two million dollars
as against John C Depp II we the jury
award punitive damages in the amount of
zero dollars
does either side wish to have the jury
pulled yes your honor all right Jamie
members of the jury if this is your
verdict please answer yes if this is not
your verdict please answer no
juror number six
juror number 10.
Journal number 15.
juror number 16.
you're you're number 22. yeah
Journal number 27
Journal number 29.
I do find that the jury's verdict is
unanimous ladies and gentlemen this
concludes your service in this case